Riddler's asking for you
look there's latest it's all
about the wings you lied to me
maybe this is all coming to an end
i got you
some event huh brought out the one guy in the
city more reclusive than me thought you'd never
leave the shoreline aren't you afraid someone took
a shot at you why because your father ain't around
eyes you know bruce wayne wow is that right his
father saved my life i got shot in the chest right
here i couldn't go to the hospital so we showed
up on his doorstep operated right on the dining
room table kid hearing he saw the whole thing up
on the stairs looking down i remember your face
you don't think that meant something you did then
it means you took the hippocratic off hypocritical
that's good
you're pretty good at that
hey give me that
Welcome back everyone this
is my new batman trailer video there's a
whole bunch of new scenes and footage so we'll
break it all down the movie's out this week so
if you're brand new to the channel i am doing
a giveaway for movie tickets all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and just leave your
favorite moment from any batman movie on the video
i'm supposed to be seeing the movie monday night
so my review will probably post tuesday morning so
look out for that be sure to go see the movie as
soon as you get the chance but one of the coolest
things here is that big scene of carmine falcone
bruce wayne meeting carmine falcone as an adult
not totally remembering their shared history
together and it's this big scene from batman the
long halloween that a lot of you longtime comic
book fans will remember a lot of scenes from the
movie are directly ripped right out of batman the
long halloween although they've changed some of
the story so it's not literally a copy paste
version of the long halloween in live action
but if you're getting long halloween vibes
from a lot of these scenes it's on purpose
matt reeves even said that one of his early
screenwriting teachers at usc who encouraged him
to become a filmmaker was jeff loeb the person who
wrote batman the long halloween so the circle of
easter eggs is now complete the student has become
the master when carmine falcone is telling bruce
wayne this story about how he came to the steps
of wayne manor bleeding out asking his father
thomas wayne for help because he was a doctor and
he couldn't go to a hospital because the police
would have arrested him that's a moment that
came right out of the long halloween during the
long halloween carmine falcone tells this story to
bruce wayne and it's while he's trying to get him
to bring his billions of dollars to mob controlled
banks but in the comic book bruce wayne doesn't
want to have anything to do with him so it's a
very similar vibe during the movie bruce wayne as
an adult in the movie only sees him as this really
evil figure in gotham who's slowly destroying the
city so he's trying to do everything he can to
get rid of him but as he says he rarely leaves
the docks this is only batman year two so he's
still trying to find a way to take him down and
the reason why he hasn't done it yet is just
because he hasn't found the right opportunity
but carmine tells in this story about how as a
child he saw him watching them from the staircase
as he was bleeding out on their table like in
their living room as his father stitched him up
and he feels like that connects them somehow like
that moment was such an important event in his
life that bruce wayne was a part of he thinks it
connects them in this deep way even though as i
said bruce wayne in this moment here doesn't want
to have anything to do with him the reason why he
mostly stays at the shoreline as bruce wayne says
is because that's basically the area around the
docks that the mob controls it's how they import
and export all their illegal goods from gotham
the other big action scene where batman goes after
penguin in the batmobile also a really cool scene
takes place near the docks it seems like during
the events of this movie penguin is a relatively
low ranking member of carmine falcone's crime
family the way they explain penguin's arc
through this next era of matt reeves robert
pattinson batman is that it's going to sort of
be like scarface inside the batman universe and
they'll really dig into that during the penguin
batman hbo series that they're going to be doing
in the next couple of years we're doing a penguin
show with colin which is going to be super cool
and we're doing working some other stuff too
but we have started talking about another movie
but you know right now we'll just put it out in
the world i'll try to enjoy this but i think the
scene of bruce hearing the story of how his father
thomas wayne saved carmine's life is probably
meant to foreshadow how batman later in the movie
will be forced to try and save his life
when the riddler targets him eventually
targets carmine even though he doesn't want to
save carmine is this classic batman moral argument
do you kill the villains or do you let them
die so that they won't return and do the same
thing again in the future they had a huge joke
about this during the peacemaker episodes when
peacemaker was arguing with that old man neighbor
who's a batman stan about why he thought batman
was terrible because he always tried to take his
villains to prison you see batman doesn't kill
people because he's a he's a dark creature of the
night he's a jackass who wrestles with murderers
dressed like clowns and throws them in prison
and if it wasn't clear during the peacemaker
episodes when they were talking about batman he
was referencing ben affleck's batman because the
series takes place inside the dc eu unlike the
batman movie which is taking place on earth too
completely different universe the clip of batman
fighting catwoman for that little book from the
safe also seems like it's taking place inside the
mayor's old house where they found his body but it
could be someone else's house because this scene
is also right out of batman the long halloween
in the original comic book it was
taking place in carmine falcone's house
after he'd been murdered by the holiday killer
but in the movie this seems like it's one of
batman and catwoman's earlier encounters between
the two of them so it seems like it's happening
relatively early in the film which is why i think
that it might be the mayor's house because the
way they've been presenting all these trailers it
seems like he's one of the riddlers first victims
but the actual book that they're fighting over
probably just contains some evidence linking
all of the riddler's victims to some larger
plot involving gotham city's renewal project
the riddler's tragic backstory maybe the gotham
city orphanage that's what this other scene is
all about too batman's standing in the center of
this giant chart trying to plot the connection
between all these victims there's also another
clip of batman and alfred talking separately
about wayne enterprises and it's all about batman
not caring about the day-to-day bruce wayne stuff
that he has to do as heir to this massive fortune
in wayne enterprises fortune 500 company counting
friends at wayne enterprises are coming for
breakfast here why because i couldn't get you to
go there i haven't got time for this it's getting
serious bruce if this continues it won't be long
before you nothing i don't care about that any
of that you don't care about your family's legacy
what i'm doing is my family's legacy alfred is
basically telling him that the accountants from
wayne enterprises are coming to visit him quote
unquote to talk about some of the ways he's
spending money or not spending money the way that
all versions of batman blow through their wealth
through the act of just being batman just spending
it on being batman all their gear all their
technology the way that robert pattinson explained
batman at this point in his career is that he has
no interest in bringing bruce wayne like he thinks
of himself mostly as batman he spends all of his
time that he can being batman that's why carmine
falcone is joking with him about him being even
more scarce than he is like i'm a mob boss and
somehow you are more scarce than i am in public
speaking of batman's gear 2 there is a new clip
where robert pattinson talks about this current
version of the bat suit and obviously it's a very
early version of the suit it will evolve over time
the suit does not make him invincible it's
just a few panels of bulletproof armor
and the rest is how much bruce believes in it
and how much his adversaries are scared of it
i like the handmade nature of
everything you can see the construction
it's an element of showing how do
it yourself his version of batman is
his tactical knife is actually stored as part
of his chest plate and is actually his bat logo
even the batmobile looks like something
he's built himself in his basement
other way he basically says that the suit is just
like a couple pieces of bulletproof armor stitched
together and that's it they also confirmed this
long-running fan theory that we all had when they
dropped the first test footage of the actual suit
everyone saw the batman symbol in his chest there
and thought you know what it actually seems like
he could pull that out and use that as a weapon
the costume designer the props people confirmed
that that is his tactical knife like it's his
bat symbol but he can also pull it out and use it
as a tactical knife but like i said the movie's
coming out next week be sure to go see it when you
get the chance i'll name a giveaway winner when i
post my review video on tuesday all my easter
egg videos my full breakdown any post credit
scenes that they have all that stuff we'll start
posting later next week after the movie comes out
in theaters so be sure to enable alerts for my
channel so you don't miss that everyone click
here to learn about mr freeze showing up in the
future batman sequels in the spin-off series and
click here for my brand new morbius trailer video
with andrew garfield and tobey maguire easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!